bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau un jour un fossile ou
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de ma
première et de ma seule rencontre en
fait avec girafe à titan alors pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas girafe à titan
pour ceux qui auraient passé les dix
dernières années ces dix dernières
années dans une grotte girafe à titan
c'est ce qu'on appelait autrefois
brachiosaures us donc ça veut pas dire
que braquer aux eaux russes n'existe
plus ça veut juste dire que il y avait
autrefois de braquer aux russes celui
d'amérique du nord celui d'afrique etc
en fait celui d'afrique est vachement
plus complet est un peu différent de
celui d'amérique du nord via notamment
des différences sur le bassin et une
différence notable au niveau de la cage
thoracique qui est beaucoup plus
allongée de haut en bas chez bras chez
girafe à titan que chez bras qui osent
aux russes donc donc les spécialistes
ont décidé de renommer braquer aux orris
d'afrique girafe à titan et pourquoi ils
n'ont pas décidé de renommer plutôt
celui d'amérique parce que c'est celui
d'amérique qui a été trouvée le premier
donc voilà donc girafe à titan c'est ce
qu'on appelait autrefois brachiosaures
russe s'est en fait c'est en fait le
modèle de base d'à peu près tous les
bras qui osent aux russes avant les
années 2000 c'est à dire que la braquer
aux orris d'amérique du nord et un
squelette un peu pourri alors que le
brachiosaure us d'afrique était un super
squelette donc quasiment toutes les
images que vous avez pu voir deux bras
qui osent aux russes qui date d'avant
les années 2000 basse est en fait dû
girafe à titan ou du moins c'est inspiré
beaucoup plus de girafe à titan que du
vrai bras qui autorise d'amérique du
nord ce qui inclut aussi jurassic park 1
donc en fait le brachiosaure eu ce que
vous voyez dans le premier jurassic park
le tout premier dinosaure d'ailleurs que
vous voyez dans le tout premier jurassic
park basse est en fait un girafe à titan
en tout cas il aimait beaucoup plus
inspiré du squelette complet de girafe à
titan qu'il ne l'ait du squelette pas
beau de braquet aux eaux russes pas beau
et pas complète brachiosaures us donc en
fait le premier dinosaure que vous voyez
dans la saga jurassic park c'est un
dinosaure africain alors comment décrire
ma première rencontre avec girafe à
titan c'est vraiment une
un truc assez ouf devoir girafe à titan
pour la première fois donc girafe à
titan c'est le premier truc que vous
voyez en passant la porte du museum à
berlin
c'est la galerie d'exposition où il se
trouve c'est le premier truc et il est
droit en face de vous quand vous rentrez
dans le muséum donc vous juste vous
grimpé les marches on la porte s'ouvre
et bam vous êtes droit en face de lui et
moi j'y suis allé un jour il pleuvait
parce que je devais bosser à berlin en
extérieur mais que du coup je m'étais
trouvé je m'étais trouvé au chômage
technique vu qu'il pleuvait donc du coup
j'y suis allé un jour où il pleuvait
sans savoir qu'en fait les guichets sont
à l'extérieur ça prend tellement en fait
la galerie d'exposition prend tellement
la place du musée qu'en fait les
guichets pour acheter le ticket sont à
l'extérieur donc j'ai fait la queue
pendant 20 minutes dehors sous la pluie
parce qu'évidemment il n'y a pas de quoi
s'abriter donc vous faites la queue sous
la pluie là j'arrive je fais la queue
sous la pluie et du coup après vingt
minutes je rentre dans le machin je suis
complètement misérable j'ai suivi mes
lunettes et là je les remets et boum
vous levez les yeux et vous avez girafe
à titan juste devant vous un squelette
de 13 mètres de haut
donc 12 mètres dont 9 m de coûts plus un
piédestal de 1 mètre donc le truc de 13
mètres de haut avec sa lumière qui
arrivent par le dessus parce qu'à une
baie vitrée juste au dessus au sommet de
la galerie donc c'est quasiment une
vision mystique koala et j'ai un
collègue d'ailleurs qui m'a dit ça et
c'est vraiment extrêmement vrai ce qu'il
a dit il a dit ma première rencontre
avec brasil qui osent aux russes c'était
un peu le caecum rencontrer dieu quoi
c'est ce que j'ai eu de plus proche
d'une rencontre avec dieu et je suis
totalement d'accord avec lui quoi c'est
juste surnaturel ses dimensions
un squelette de cette taille là mais
c'est juste complètement surnaturel il
est gigantesque il est tellement grand
que que d'ailleurs c'est pas possible
d'en faire une photo potable tellement
il est immense c'est pas possible d'en
faire une photo complète du niveau zéro
en fait il faut grimper à l'étagé
ce qui n'est pas accessible pour le
public hélas mais voilà c'est un c'est
incroyable comme squelette il est
gigantesque et c'est vraiment vrai c'est
comme une expérience mystique de le voir
pour la première fois c'est et on peut
pas s'empêcher d'ailleurs d'entendre
dans sa tête la musique de jurassic park
je veux dire on est dans le même état
que les que les protagonistes de
jurassic park quand il voit apparaître
le brachiosaure pour la première fois le
girafe à titan pour la première fois
d'ailleurs je me corrige moi même on est
dans le même état c'est à dire c'est
l'émerveillement le plus total quoi
c'est des dimensions mais qui sont
au-delà de la compréhension humaine
grèce comment ce truc là était vivant je
veux dire comment ce truc là était
vivant donc vous entendez comme ça la
petite musique de
de jurassic park dans votre tête et vous
pouvez pas vous en empêcher et c'est
juste magique quoi c'est un instant
absolument magique et pour moi ça a été
l'occasion de voir pour la première fois
la fameuse vertèbres de la discorde
alors pour ceux qui savent pas il ya un
gros débat sur la position du coucher
girafe à titan donc est-ce qu'il tenait
sa tête comme un signe ou est ce qu'il
le tenait sa tête à l'horizontale
quand on consulte un peu les sites sur
internet on a l'impression que le débat
est clos et que la tête était tenue à
laverty qu'enfin que le coup était tenue
à la verticale comme un signe ou une
autruche
c'est pas tout à fait le cas il ya le il
ya un physiologue à paléo physiologue
physiologiste qui s'appelle roger sémou
rogers ses mots pour ceux qui parlent
l'anglophone voilà si vous parlez
english very well comme moi et en fait
il a déterminé que pour envoyer du sang
à 13 mètres au dessus du sol
le choeur de girafe à titan aurait dû
être plus gros que sa cage thoracique ne
l'est et donc on à la cage thoracique de
girafe à titan c'est exactement quelle
taille elle fait donc donc on sait très
bien que ça dépasse et que ça dépasse
pas qu'un peu et il ya cette hypothèse
selon laquelle girafe à titan aurait pu
avoir des valves et des des artères des
artères avec des valves à l'intérieur
dans le coup et que ces artères étaient
pulsatile donc des mini coeur avec des
valves qui aurait envoyé le le sang vers
le haut et les valves qui empêche le
sang de retomber en fait comme les
girafes
sauf que voilà
j'ai un
j'ai un collègue vétérinaire qui a
disséqué les girafes récemment et qui
m'a dit qu'il n'arrive pas à retrouver
ces fameuses valve et donc ça ça pose un
peu problème il ya un truc il ya un truc
aussi à propos des girafes à savoir
c'est qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
dissection qui ont été faites de girafes
du moins pas pour aller rechercher les
les artères du cou donc il ya un bouquin
fameux de jean-louis at heart en berger
que je vous recommande je vous mets la
couverture là pour que vous puissiez
retrouver qui parle de l'anatomie des
girafes et qu'il en ait qui en parle
très très bien et dans ce bouquin il dit
que les dissections de girafes ça se
compte sur les doigts d'une main
on n'a pas disséquée beaucoup de girafes
dans l'histoire des sciences et du coup
ce serait à peine surprenant finalement
que qu'en fait cette histoire de valve
elle soit elle est un peu étaient
exagérées on va dire en tout cas là le
mon collègue mon collègue veto et ben
apparemment il il n'arrive pas à
retrouver ces fameuses valve donc donc
de là à dire que j rafati temps n'avait
pas de valve comme ça et que du coup il
n'y a aucune chance qu'il ait pu tenir
sa tête de cette façon ça ça y est il
n'y a qu'un pas il ya vraiment qu'un pas
un tout petit pas en réalité
et en plus il aurait fallu aussi que le
que le cerveau supporte la pression
artérielle
quand il baisse la tête parce qu'il
fallait bien qu'ils boivent le girafe à
titan et vous imaginez vous déjà vous
quand vous vous relevez de votre chef
vous avez des vertiges
quand vous vous relevez de votre chaise
un peu vite vous avez les vertiges
imaginez girafe à titan qui doit baisser
sa tête jusqu'au niveau de l'eau pour
pouvoir boire et remonter sa tête
ensuite le dire il se prend je ne sais
pas combien de bars de pression dans le
cerveau quand il descend la tête et hop
d'un seul coup il retire tout ça quand
ça part c'est quand même biologiquement
sérieusement difficile d'imaginer que
j'ai rafati tente hoeness à son cou à la
verticale et il y à la fameuse vertèbres
de la discorde qui a été pointée du
doigt dans un article de 2013 je vous
mets l'image
ici c'est qu'en fait la vertèbre à la
base du cou de girafe à titan sur le
spécimen montée bassett une vertèbre
inventé entre guillemets reconstitué
avec liberté artistique afin justement
que le couple puisse être tenu comme
celui d'un signe et non pas à
l'horizontale parce qu'on a la vertèbre
original et que en fait
enfin on a tout les vertèbres original
et que ses vertèbres originales elles
sont toutes alignées elles sont
complètement droite elles sont pas du
tout en s comme elle devrait l'être si
le coup était tenue tel qu'il l'est sur
le spécimen montée de girafe à titan est
donc la vertèbre de base a été modifiée
pour pouvoir permettre cette posture et
ça et ça c'est pas un truc
souvent représenté un autre truc à
propos de cette exposition de girafe à
titan c'est que le cartel montre encore
le nombre acquis aux eaux russes donc
pour le coup je parlais de ceux qui
vivent dans leur grotte depuis dix ans
bah là ça doit faire un moment que les
responsables de cette exposition sont
pas sortis de leur grotte non plus et
donc comme je le disais au début j'ai
rafati temps il est africain
il vient de tanzanie en fait donc c'est
pour une fois c'est pas un dinosaure
nord américain qui est à l'honneur mais
ça c'est assez assez rare pour être
souligné ils viennent tanzanie et
justement il ya une controverse à ce
propos c'est que bah du coup le girafe à
titan a été collecté a été collectée à
l'époque où la tanzanie était une
colonie allemande ce qui correspond
aussi grosso merdo à l'époque où c'était
à l'époque de l'allemagne nazie à la
première exposition de girafe à titan
c'était à l'époque de l'allemagne nazie
et du coup il ya grosse controverse
historique
si je puis dire grosse controverse
historique et du coup aujourd'hui la
tanzanie aimerait bien voir son girafe à
titan revenir chez elle j'ai même un
étudiant ici qui vient de tanzanie et
qui qui m'en a parlé justement et qui me
disait que il a bossé dans plusieurs
musées en tanzanie et que ouais il ya un
gros mouvement pour pourvoir girafe à
titan revenir dans son pays d'origine et
bon ben je lui ai dit ça risque pas
d'arriver un c'est pas exactement le
sait pas exactement vers ça que les que
les musées se dirige aujourd'hui les
musées européens se dirigent aujourd'hui
mais là où il m'a bluffé par contre
c'est que il y dit oui mais
ils veulent même pas envoyé un moulage
c'est à dire ils veulent même pas
envoyer une copie de du squelette de
girafe à titan et ça c'est quand même
assez ouf quoi sachant qu'ils ont scanné
le squelette tout entier ils peuvent
il pourrait imprimer un truc en 3d où il
pourrait comme je disais faire ou faire
un moulage ça coûte moins cher quand
même que l'imprimé en 3d un gros truc
comme ça
enfin voilà le fc chooz même pas un
moulage
c'est chaud quoi donc voila j rafati
temps c'est c'est un spécimen
extrêmement impressionnant à voir
c'est un énorme pincement au coeur c'est
une expérience extraordinaire et c'est
un fossile dont on a à mon avis pas fini
d'entendre parler même s'il a été
découvert il ya presque cent ans
maintenant voilà c'était girafe à titan
n'hésitez pas à me dire ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires
demain je ne pense pas qu'il y aura de
un jour un fossile parce que j'ai une
interview avec avec un spécialiste du
paléocène pour vous parler de ses
récentes découvertes sur les la survie
des mammifères au début du paléocène
donc je vous dis à demain pour une
nouvelle vidéo mais ce ne sera pas un
jour un fossile allez ciao